[Applause]
[Music]
keep this date fresh in your mind the
2nd of december 2010 on that day fifa
the international federation of the most
influential sport in the world awarded
qatar the hosting of the 2022 world cup
a decision that for qatar one of the
richest countries in the world meant
launching one of the largest investment
plans in history we are talking about
hold onto your chair almost 200 billion
dollars and yes you heard correctly we
didn't add any zeros 200 billion
obviously not all of this enormous sum
of money is directly related to the
world cup rather this event has been the
perfect excuse for the qatari government
to push ahead with a huge plan to
modernize the emirate so we are not just
talking about modern football stadiums
in which the qatari government is going
to spend some six billion dollars but
also new highways railway lines a new
186 mile or 300 kilometer metro network
at a cost of almost 40 billion dollars
on the expansion of hamad airport into
one of the most modern largest and
luxurious airports in the world
in other words the 2022 world cup has
become in the government's eyes a kind
of turning point for a new era of
modernity and prosperity the perfect
icing on the cake for an economy that
has grown almost tenfold since the turn
of the century making this small emirate
one of the richest countries in the
world however hold on a minute
visualpolitik fans because not
everything is so idyllic
all kinds of suspicions and a huge wave
of criticism have also arisen around
this world cup so much that many
international organizations have come to
call it the world cup of shame something
that has caused us here at visualpolitik
to ask ourselves a few questions why on
earth is guitar so keen to host a world
cup and why does it consider it such a
big deal what's behind all the
suspicions surrounding it what's the
reason stay tuned because in this video
we are going to answer all of these
questions so let's get cracking
[Music]
the power of sport
let's not fool ourselves things have
improved tremendously perhaps much more
than we've been able to imagine just a
few years ago the truth is that despite
this the countries of the persian gulf
remain very rigid tyrannies with a lot
of restrictions on the most basic of
human rights and you know what seen from
this perspective what is known as sports
diplomacy has become a pillar of the
political strategy for each of these
countries for four fundamental reasons
firstly because in the face of so many
restrictions on women the lgbtq
population many immigrants are simply in
the face of potentially rebellious
journalists sport allows these countries
to sell a completely different image an
image of modernity competition success
all positive attributes is what is known
as sport washing exactly what many
companies do with the environment but
using sports competitions instead of the
environment
secondly because thanks to sport these
countries can achieve much more
international prominence be better known
and have more influence think for
example precisely of the case of qatar a
country that has been living in fear of
a saudi invasion for years if you
regularly watch visualpolitik and why
wouldn't you we're great you probably
already know that both saudi arabia and
the emirates don't get along
particularly well with qatar and
obviously the better known a country is
the better its international image and
the more influence it achieves the more
difficult it will be for another country
to take it by force is something similar
to what many russian oligarchs did for
many years to protect themselves from
the fury of the kremlin the better known
they were the harder it would be to put
them in the crosshairs
[Music]
certainly because you all know the
countries of the persian gulf are very
very dependent on the exploitation of
oil or natural gas that's precisely why
they have been trying to diversify their
economies for years well sports can play
a very important role here both to
promote tourism and for the development
of other activities there are for
example the case of spin sports or abu
dhabi sports two large television
production and broadcasting platforms
that are developing a whole new industry
of sports journalists analysts
programmers and advertising experts in
the case of bn sports for example it
owns a whole lot of television rates to
many of the biggest competitions in the
world
and fourth what the hell because they
can afford after all if you have literal
mountains of money you want to use it
for something right for example to be
the main player in the biggest events
[Music]
well the fact is that for all these
reasons the countries of the persian
gulf have been betting heavily on sports
in recent years they are creating
national sports leagues training centers
they are attracting athletes and sports
professionals from all corners of the
world organizing major international
sporting events and they're even buying
some of the world's best known teams we
are talking about cases such as paris
saint-germain manchester city new york
city fc the repeated attempts to buy
manchester united or the latest
acquisition of the saudi government
saudi newcastle soccer takeover prompts
sport-washing concerns saudi arabia is
the latest petro state to buy up a
western sporting franchise in what
experts say is an attempt to boost its
image abroad however all of the petrol
monarchies in the persian gulf the one
that has gone much further in this
matter is precisely qatar because when
it comes to the sports industry believe
me when i say that qatar plays in a
different league check this out
[Music]
qatar's big signings
with a population of just 350 000
qataris and 2 million immigrants qatar a
small peninsula in the middle east is a
very very wealthy country this is
particularly thanks to being the world's
largest exporter of liquefied natural
gas however the country has been trying
to diversify its economy for years and
precisely to achieve this in 2008 they
launched their vision 2030 a strategy a
plan to turn qatar into a developed and
competitive country beyond hydrocarbons
well in this strategy sport and in
particular the king of sports football
were prominent elements of this
modernization plan
the aim was that sports and particularly
football would boost tourism qatar's
image in the world and also its
political influence in other words they
wanted to turn football into a gigantic
advertising campaign in order to achieve
this in 2011 the qatari government
bought psg the biggest football club in
france of course the arrival of the new
owners was accompanied by a huge influx
of money and with it came a host of
stars such as ibrahimovic beckham neymar
mumbai dimaria ramos and lionel messi
himself
in fact the two most extensive signings
in the history of football were made by
this team i'm talking about the 252
million signing of neymar and the 204
million arrival of mbappe all so that
psg could be a real showcase for the
country and its revitalized football
industry for example the psg president
was in turn appointed president of the
european club association a position
that also placed him directly on the
uefa executive council a more than
influential position when it comes to
for example encouraging many big teams
to spend training periods in the emirate
but that's not all in addition over the
years they have also developed their own
national league because that was
essentially the idea for world famous
stars to live in qatar and become true
ambassadors for the country
zavi hernandez the criticism of qatar is
unfounded it's a generous and hospicable
country david beckham signs 150 million
pound deal to be an ambassador for qatar
but the biggest challenge came in 2010
with the awarding of the hosting of the
2022 world cup the shakes of qatar had
the strategy very clear this was the
year the perfect moment to show the
world the best image of a modern
developed and prosperous country think
about it what better showcase than to
have the whole world watching well you
know what no sooner said than done
since 2010 they have been executing a
huge investment plan of almost 200
billion dollars that has completely
transformed the emirate the metro the
airport new highways thousands of new
hotel rooms promenades even a new island
city lucid deal located about 9 miles or
15 kilometers from doha a city that will
have marinas residential areas shopping
malls luxury shops beaches and two golf
courses it's part of a final phase of
the world cup and for at least 10 years
the guitar formula one grand prix will
be held there and of course among the
projects that have gone ahead are some
of the most modern stadiums in the world
including the first air conditioned
stadium and the first demountable
stadium 2022 is the year chosen for its
launch however visualpolitik fans things
have become somewhat complicated to the
extent that the emirates shot could
backfire or at least the world cup might
be slightly less glitzy than expected
why check this out
[Music]
a world cup under suspicion
when you think about it qatar is perhaps
one of the worst possible destinations
to host a world cup or any other major
international competition because while
it is true the country has made a lot of
progress and in many areas it is almost
a role model as far as winning an
international bid to host what is
perhaps the most important sporting
competition in the world
[Music]
and let's see despite the great
improvements that have taken place we
are talking about a country with a very
harsh climatic conditions with a poor
record of respect for human rights where
the media is not entirely free where
homosexuality is criminalized and where
women are not fully equal in rights to
men to make matters worse in november
2010 a fifa technical report stated that
qatar was the only candidate that
presented high operational risks as a
host among other factors this was
because the infrastructure was not yet
in place
so of course if you take all these
things into account and you consider
that the rivals were strong candidates
such as japan the usa south korea and
new zealand and what can i say it's
strange that qatar was chosen don't you
agree choosing guitars bed even meant
turning the entire world football
calendar upside down why well because
given the extremely harsh weather
conditions very hot and very humid the
world cup will have to be held during
the month of november and december which
means a complete interruption of a
calendar of the world's most important
leagues la liga the premier league serie
a the bundesliga etc etc etc so then why
exactly did they choose qatar well let's
just say that since the announcement a
lot of theories or rather a lot of
pieces of evidence have emerged
blatter and platini face fraud charges
in fifa corruption probe the former
world and european football chiefs
accused by swiss authorities of
receiving a two million dollar bribe
since the awarding of the world cup to
qatar a lot of evidence and witness
accounts have emerged pointing to
massive corruption in the election
process for example a whistleblower
framed cameroon's isa hayatu and ivorian
jacuzz altoma for receiving 1.5 million
dollars in exchange for a vote for qatar
then mohammed bin hammam president of
the asian football confederation and a
strong candidate for the fifa presidency
was accused of bribing 25 officials to
vote for qatar and in fact after these
re-elevations he was banned for life and
these are just two examples
[Music]
in 2012 in light of all the scandals
that were emerging michael garcia a
former new york lawyer and judge who
chaired fifa's ethics committee
investigated fifa for alleged corruption
for two years he conducted an exhaustive
investigation from which the 350 page
findings became known as the garcia
report fifa decided to put the report in
a dryer and publish only a summary that
did not incriminate anyone
[Music]
in protest michael garcia resigned from
his position and do you know what when
the report was leaked years later it
said such obvious things as the members
of the executive committee studying the
negative aspects of qatar's bid didn't
even include the harsh weather
conditions or the disruption it would
cause to the world football calendar
nothing at all qatar had to win at all
costs so after a myriad of allegations
including the fbi's arrests in 2015 of
11 officials accused of corruption and
who had participated in the vote
supporting qatar i think we can all get
an idea of the motives that really made
this emirate the winner what's more in
2019 it was discovered that al jazeera
had offered 400 million dollars in
exchange for securing the tv rights to
the tournament including an additional
100 million dollars if qatar won the bid
[Applause]
[Music]
well what can i say fifa is just kind of
like that but this is not the only dodgy
aspect surrounding the world cup in
qatar the harsh conditions faced by
low-cost migrants arriving in qatar to
work have been another major source of
controversy you see more than 6500
migrant workers from india pakistan
nepal bangladesh and sri lanka have died
in qatar since the emirate won the right
to host the world cup 10 years ago the
vast majority of them did not die on
stadium construction sites but
presumably did die on infrastructure
work associated with the world cup in
qatar
the sweltering heat the lack of safety
measures or the kafala system now
fortunately no longer in use which
turned workers from poor countries to
virtual slaves were surely major causes
of all these strategies for those of you
who don't know it the kofala system is
where the employer is legally
responsible for the worker so that even
to leave the country you need the
approval of the boss and of course this
means that workers cannot complain or
change jobs
in any case returning to the 6500
fatalities it's clear that these are
appalling figures for such a wealthy
country but they have not shocked their
countries of origin why well because
according to data from the indian
government occupational mortality in
this country is much higher than in
qatar be that as it may from such a rich
gas power as qatari emirate one would
expect something different
so all this high labor mortality along
with the terrible living conditions and
the very long working hours of these
workers have made many international
organizations denounce this world cup as
the world cup of shame fortunately all
these criticisms led qatar to change its
entire labor regulations from top to
bottom it adopted welfare standards and
put an end to the perverse kafala system
well i guess that's the upside of the
world cup concession in any case we need
to be careful with the negative news
because well let's just say that there
is a media war between the governments
of qatar and the emirates and saudi
arabia and of course damaging the world
cup is seen by the qatari bet as the
biggest blow that this emirate can
receive today so visualpolitik fans
these are the reasons that have made
qatar the most expensive world cup of
all time and also the suspicions and
criticisms that have clouded the good
image that the emirate hoped to achieve
having said that who do you think will
be the winner of this world cup well
things go as well for qatar's interests
as it government's hopes leave your
answers below in the comments and now if
you found this video interesting don't
forget to like and subscribe to
visualpolitik thanks very much for
watching and i'll see you next time
[Music]
you